[Applause]
well I think that's a first being
introduced to the musical number I put
that down as a first so yes so I'm going
to talk to you for the next in a while
about solving layout problems with CSS
grid and some of its friends and these
are some of the things about me and
places that you can find me I'm on
Twitter as that Mitch Landrieu and
that's my website which Long's don't
code it UK and the context of this talk
what's probably most useful to know is
that I'm an invited expert to the CSS
working group which means that I get to
spend time a few times a year sat in the
room with other people arguing about of
the size of margins and so on
so I'm kind of part of making CSS as it
were that I'm not to blame for all of it
now I've been talking about CSS grid
layout for over five years at this point
I've got very excited I first saw the
spec in an early form and so I've made
it my mission to go around and tell
people about it and hope that eventually
would get into browsers and earlier this
year CSS grid layout shipped in seven of
our browsers into Chrome and Firefox and
opera and Safari and it's about to ship
in an updated form into edge and as I go
around and tell people about grid layout
the kind of top question I get asked at
this point is don't you realize that
flexbox exists can't you do all of this
stuff with flexbox and at some point
I'll be able to take this piece out of
all of my talks but it's such a sort of
top question I like to try and answer it
so defined in the grid specification is
the biggest and most obvious reason why
we might want to use grid rather than
flexbox flexbox has been designed as a
one-dimensional specification and grid
as to so one-dimensional means do I want
to lay something out as a row or as a
column where as two-dimensional is I'd
like to lay these things out in rows and
columns at the same time here's a quick
example this is a flex layout now this
would grow and Sri
to distribute content according to the
available screen width and if you look
at the last row there were fewer items
and so they've just split the space
that's what flexbox does every time we
wrap onto a new row the space
distribution happens across that row as
if it's a completely new flex container
and that's layout in one dimension
we're just worrying about the rows how
many things fit in this row and let's
just spread them out along the row you
can't easily line the things up at the
bottom with the things above so making
say box 9 there line up underneath one
and 5 if you want to line things up in
columns what you actually need to do is
start breaking the flexibility of
flexbox
or start setting percentage whit's and
everything so they all line up next to
each other so this is doing the same
sort of thing with grid and you can see
the same kind of layout and a browser
this would grow and shrink with the
browser window but the items are lined
up here in rows and in columns and
that's what we mean by two-dimensional
you can get both of those dimensions at
once and this is the key thing with grid
layout we're working from the container
in we're saying here is my grid it's got
these rows and columns and I'm going to
put things into them whereas everything
else we don't work like that everything
else we work on sizing the individual
items and then kind of pushing
everything around so it looks like a
grid so let's have a quick look at that
this is a simplified float grid example
now pretty much the bare bones of any
float based grid system so sort of older
versions of bootstrap and foundation
we're doing this and other things that
do floats there I think Suzy was
originally float based and worked like
this so you have row wrappers because
you need to clear things so you have a
row wrapper and you put your things
inside that wrapper and then you use
percentages so you can have a nice
flexible grid you create these
percentages and then you have to have a
percentage gutter as well using the
margin and make sure that everything
adds up to 100% or it all goes horribly
wrong so we end up with this kind of
thing so we're doing these these
sort of stones somewhere whether we do
that in SAS or we add it up with the
calculator and put it into our CSS or
whether we use calc we're having to do
that kind of math and the key thing is
there isn't a grid we're faking the
appearance of a grid because we're doing
the work of lining everything up
and so what about flexbox based grid
frameworks I mean they exist there's a
lot of them a lot of people have moved
their float based framework over to flex
box and flex box does work on the
container you say display flex the
children all become flex items but they
don't become a grid and to get a grid
you have to add widths to the Flex items
in some way and so again we have
wrappers this time we use the row graph
as usually as a Flex container and then
we add widths to the items and using
Flex basis and having that flex pages of
auto and a width from the item so we
don't have to do any clearing so that's
an improvement over our float based
layout and we're able to use the
alignment features of flex box that's
the key thing really if we go to flex
box we can use all that nice alignment
stuff so that helps but we're not really
using flexbox of what it's good at and
we're still doing all of the math so
here we have a grid layout you know
you're using a grid using grid layout
and we don't have to do the maths what
happens on the item is a simple
instruction just how many tracks should
I span so it's a very different concept
what we're doing here is we're defining
the size of the columns when we set up
the tracks we then just tell the items
how many columns to span and there's a
few ways we can do that using grid
layout but the sizing is all happening
on the container and we don't have
anything else in CSS that really behaves
like this as this is something to
remember the grid frameworks we've got
that aren't using CSS grid layout they
create something that looks like a grid
by controlling item size whereas a CSS
grid layout you create an actual grid
and you put your items into it
so CSS grid layout is basically a CSS
framework built right into your browser
and it isn't any wonder that people are
puzzled and keep sending me their
attempt at doing grid based grid
frameworks and they're using Rho
wrappers they're essentially forcing CSS
grid layout back into an older model and
the reason we created all those
frameworks around the older models is
that doing all of that math is boring
and error-prone no one wants to spend
their life calculating percentages so we
create frameworks you know then all we
need to do is add a class and the right
dimensions are applied and not having to
constantly do those calculations and we
don't need that stuff once we're using
grid layout the browser is doing the
maths for you computers are really good
at this stuff
you know it's much better that they do
it than we do you create the grid and
decide how many of those defined tracks
your item spans where it starts where it
ends and the sizing is worked out for
you every single abstraction I've seen
so far on top of grid layouts a sense
you just try to force it back into the
past you know don't do that so to make
this shift in thinking and then you can
really embrace what is coming you know
in the future with this stuff and I've
mentioned sizing a lot already sizing is
really important to understand when it
comes to grid layout and our newer
layout methods sizings been quite simple
in the past because we've had to sort of
say well things have got a they're
either gonna be fixed they're gonna come
in pixels and we're gonna have flexible
things with percentages and we
understand percentages might be a bit
strange numbers to put in your CSS but
we understand it sizing is kind of
getting more complicated and we need to
know a bit more about how the browser
deals with sizing to really take
advantage of new layout if we have an
example in grid of as many columns as
we'll fit and we use two methods here to
work on the grid container to enable
flexible sized tracks and as many of
those trackers we can get into a
container so we get something that looks
a bit like this so I'm saying grid
template columns
and I've got this repeat notations we
say repeat and then we've got some
brackets and basically that's just
saying browser please repeat as many
times the pattern that's inside the
brackets there and we using autofill I
could just put an interested there and
say repeat this five times what I'd
actually like is the browser to fill as
many columns as it can into the
container so I say repeat auto fills as
many as you can
now that so that could be a number or
two fills another keyword auto fit and
then we use min max min max lets us set
a minimum and a maximum value for track
size the minimum would be the smallest
size we want our columns to shrink to so
in this case I'd like that to be 200
pixels the maximum is 1fr that's one
fraction of the available space the
effect of this in our example is that
after working out how many 200 pixel
columns will fit into the container the
browser will then take the remaining
space that's left over because there
probably won't be exactly that space
divided by 200 and it will share it out
across the columns and so we've got this
F our unit which is an unusual-looking
thing we don't use that in any other
layout method and it's all about
distributing available space so you can
have different FR values for tracks so
in this case I've got a track of two FR
and then two tracks of one FR so my
available space in the container i want
to share that out into four parts and
give two parts to the first track and
one part each to the second two so we
end up with something like this now
what's really nice about these FR units
because they're distributing available
space you can mix them with fixed length
units now you can already see i've got a
gap in there which is 20 pixels so
that's taken away from the available
space before we distribute the tracks
and we can also have tracks that have
got a fixed size so here I'm saying I'd
like to have a one fr track another one
if our track and then a 400 pixel track
so the browser is going to take away the
font of pixels it's going to take away
the space you need for the gutters and
then whatever is left it's going to
share it between those two tracks and so
we ends up with this and if the space
grows and shrinks the folder pixel track
will always stay at 400 pixels it's the
other two tracks will be growing and
shrinking to take up whatever space
they've got and so this is the 12 column
grid example that I showed earlier
so the FRU that means you don't need to
worry about the fixed pixel width in the
gutter tracks that's just taken away
before we calculate how much space we've
got for 12 columns we don't need to
calculate those percentages as you can
see how the column tracks detailed on
the container there we've got these
twelve 1fr columns and they'll just grow
and shrink they can be very skinny
columns or they could be really wide
columns and so when it comes to sizing
and I think what often happens when
people come they start using grid layout
for the first time because we're working
from this old model and we've got this
old idea of how layout works the first
thing people tend to do is they try and
work out all the percentages because
that's what you're used to doing most of
the time the fr unit will replace your
need to use percentages and you can let
the browser do the calculations for you
somewhere where you might want to start
using percentages is if you're trying to
match up say some things that are using
flexbox and some things that are using
grid and you want everything to line up
and that might be a reason to use
percentages but an awful lot of the time
the fr unit will deal with that for you
and you can replace percentages with
that and then you don't have to worry
about something larger getting into the
layout and needing to be fixed with and
still needing to calculate the space
abate very briefly showed you that min
max function and I want to talk a bit
more about that because this is another
new thing that we see in grid layout
because once you're setting track sizes
you might want them to be a minimum size
and a maximum size you'd like to have
some
that can never go too small but won't go
too big and that's what min/max lets us
do it's really useful for creating these
kind of precise looking layouts but also
understand that they are on the web and
sometimes there's more content or the
content is bigger than we expected when
we lay something out so here's an
example this is a panel a bit similar to
the sort of panel of photos you get on
Facebook and so and it's of nice little
grid with different sized photos and
I've also put an introduction to the
photos there into the box now that all
sort of looks looks fairly neat and I
want my photos to be a certain size so
they all line up nicely so this is the
grid definition I'm using for that panel
I've defined column track status using
the fr unit and I'm using grid Auto rows
and that defines the sizing of rows that
grid creates in the implicit grid so
this is as we add content we haven't
actually defined a set row grid we'll
just create Auto sized rows if we want
to define how big those rows that are
created we use grid auto rows so here
I'm saying but when you create rows make
them a minimum of 200 pixels at all but
a maximum of auto and if the row is a
size of auto it'll just expand to take
whatever goes into it which is generally
what we want in the web because we don't
always know how big our content is going
to be we won't get any weird overflows
so I'm highlighting the row lines here
and you can see they're growing there to
200 pixels tall even though there's not
that much content in them and obviously
if something spans over two rows then
it's four pixels tall so this is all
fine everything's going to the right
Heights here because I've got nothing
there that is going to force any row
larger than 200 pixels so it looks nice
and neat nothing's collapsing down to
nothing but then someone comes along and
as always happens you know we've done
this very neat design expects you know
one sentence of text and someone comes
to the CMS and goes our but there's some
very important things we need to say
here and add some extra content into
that box and that's
absolutely fine with grid layout because
the box will just expand and it expands
right across the row so the next the
cell next to it in that row is also
going to have to expand and you can see
that here you can see that now that's
that second row is now taller and it's
taking that extra content and just
something you'd need to consider with
this kind of layout is that everything
across the row if the rows going to grow
that everything will cope with that so
in my case I've got an image I'm using
object fit so it sort of scales and then
fills the box there and so it sort of
will maintain that sort of appearance
that I want now it might be that in an
ideal world it should be all nice and
neat and even but this is fine we can
read it we've not got content cut off
we've not got any sort of weird gaps a
little things strange happening as you
might if you sort of tried to use
absolute positioning to make this kind
of layout I could use exactly the same
technique to add a caption I've made the
figure actually a two row track grid and
causing the image to span over two rows
and then placing the caption in row two
so it overlays the image I've given that
caption a minimum height of 100 pixels
and once again a max of auto which gives
us this and you can see something here
the captions at the bottom there don't
line up the one on the left has got
taller because it's got two lines due to
our use of min Max and they're part of a
nested grid they don't have relationship
to each other we can't ask at the moment
the caption for the colorful balloon
there and to be as tall as the one on
the left and I'll talk a bit more later
about this issue of nesting grids and
the fact that you know a nested grid is
essentially a completely new grid it's
not got any relationship to the parent
at the moment but before that I want to
continue a little while on sizing
because we've seen that we define grids
on the parent and then we placed our
content into the cells we've also seen
that content can to some extent define
the size of tracts with our min max
we've
put extra content it's actually defining
the size of that tract because we're
using auto you have to remember though
that unlike flexbox when you change the
track sizing it's going to change it
right across the row or if you're
working in a column right down the
column and so we've got some new sizing
keywords to help with sort of playing
around with track sizing and they're not
just for grid layout and these size and
keywords are going to start pairing in
other places but they've been
implemented with grid layout so you can
have a look at those now so these are
some interesting new sizing keywords
that are defined in CSS sizing three so
this is another specification what you
find with new CSS specifications they're
becoming quite broken down so we've
obviously got CSS grid layout and it
refers to things that are in sizing and
things that are in box alignment because
those features may also be used in other
layout methods so for instance all the
nice alignment stuff that we have in
Flex box is in box alignments that grid
layout can use it and in the future
other things might use it too so to look
at our sizing we need to go and have a
look at the sizing spec I'm going to
take a look at min content max content
and fit content so this is min content
I'm defining here a grid and my first
column the first column track is sized
min content and then we've got two one
if our columns so min content basically
and in grid light will display the track
to be as small as it can possibly be if
all of the soft wrapping opportunities
are taken into account so you can see
that what's holding that track
the width of it is being is the word
content there is what's making the width
of that it's wrapped as small as it
possibly can now that's going to work
right across the column right down the
column so if there was something bigger
in the box that's got seven in it if
that that would then define the size of
it it's going to look for the smallest
it can possibly make it without anything
overflowing and then we have the
opposite we have max content so max
content will sort of spread everything
out as wide as it can it will not take
any wrapping opportunities
so you're going to end up with something
like this and if it was a longer
sentence or a paragraph in there that
it's gonna cause overflows the things
that's going to keep on going it's going
to keep on growing
that's max content getting as big as we
possibly can get if we don't take
advantage of any soft trapping
opportunities but then we have something
that's kind of in the middle and that's
fit content so if we have a track I've
bits fit content if I don't define two
tracks to fit content here we've got the
first and the second track of both using
fit content and we have the fit content
and then we pass in a value and I'm
passing in 200 pixels and what happens
here is the track will act like max
content until it gets to the size that
you've passed in and then it will stop
so we get this so both of those tracks
are using fit content 200 pixels
the first has got more content in than
200 pixels so it starts to spread out it
starts to spread out it hits too little
pixels then it starts to wrap it's not
going to get bigger the next track the
x-column track it's also fit content but
it's only got those numbers in it 2 3 &
5 they're not very big so it displays
the number and that's fine that's max
content for that track so it stops so
fit content really really useful lets
user to play around with the sizing of
your tracks looking at the different way
is to size tracks in grid layout gives
you an awful lot of power and an awful
lot of ways to create interesting source
of grids you know don't think oh it has
to be like a 12 column grid because
that's what we're used to using you've
got far more tools than that you know to
play with so do have a play around with
sizing and the different ways you can
define track sizes because you can find
you can create all sorts of interesting
looking things and things that don't
really look like a grid you know when
people just sort of look at that on the
webpage you've got that grid underlying
holding everything in place but then we
can't talk about this stuff or that
talking about old browsers because if I
don't talk about it to you you will talk
about it to me so
so here we are old browsers but CSS is
going to help you with old browsers
because you know I've been doing this
since before CSS I remember Netscape for
anybody else
there we go you say we're not not all
just really young so that we're CSS it
knows about our browsers the CSS working
group know about our browsers and we're
trying to help with that so the nice
thing about all these new layout methods
are flexbox and grid defined in their
specifications is what they do if you
have something using the old layout
method and then you make it into a flex
or a grid item so with grid you might
want to float things and then make those
items into grid items later that's fine
if something's floated and it becomes a
grid item all the float sort of
properties and the way float of things
behave that just kind of gets thrown
away and the same with clear so you can
have something floated you can then turn
it into a grid item there won't be any
sort of weird floaty behavior kind of
hanging around and causing you any
problems inline block is a pretty nice
way to line up a bunch of things but you
get some sort of weird problems when you
use inline block because it's
essentially an inline element like a
word you get whitespace so unless you
sort of bunch all your markup up you get
to the problems where you can't you know
you can't quite line things so if you
can't quite close the gap because of the
whitespace if an inline block item
becomes a grid item all that sort of
inline type behavior goes away the item
becomes what we call block off ID and so
it stops behaving like an inline item so
you can have something using inline
block and then basically just overwrite
that with grid layout and that's all
perfectly safe if you're looking for
fall backs for grid display table making
things into table cell which allow it
lets you use vertical at vertical align
that's quite a good way to create fall
backs from very old browsers now you
know if you need a support sold versions
of ie and so on and again you can
overwrite table display with grid layout
very easily one of the things that
happens when you use display:table-cell
is that you get what we call it in
nice boxes so essentially have like
phantom boxes that you didn't insert
yourself in the markup to fix up the
table display because a table a table
sale has a table row and a table around
it and they're kind of needed to display
it properly what happens is the thing
becomes a grid item before those things
are created so you never get them so you
don't have weird stuff lying around it's
going to cause a problem so you can use
display table as a way around an
vertical line which works on inline
block and display:table-cell items if
you have used that and then the thing
becomes a grid item well vertical line
does not apply in grid layout or in flex
layout and so that will just also get
thrown away by the browser and don't
forget our friend multiple column layout
has really good browser support for this
little basics of multi-core and if you
want to do things like layout a set of
cards or whatever and they're going to
go row by column wise rather than row
wise by default but you know you can use
multi call as a bit of a fallback if
you've declared column count or column
width properties on a container which
then becomes a grid container they'll
just get thrown away they want sort of
end up competing and you potentially
used flex layout as a fallback for grid
layout flex layouts got better support
than grid and if something is a flex
item then it becomes a grid item the
Flex properties that are defined on the
child item that's that's now a grid item
they'll just get thrown away so you can
use flexbox as a fallback for grid and
of course all of the alignment
properties are the same through the two
specs pretty much so you can you know
take advantage of alignment if you're
using flex as a fallback and I think as
time goes on using flex as your fallback
will probably be a pretty good thing to
be doing what this does mean though is
that you need to know about CSS you need
to be able to know that to use the
Cascade to write your CSS for old
browsers then write your CSS for new
browsers as long as your grid code comes
last browsers to understand the first
stuff but don't understand the grid
stuff they'll do the first stuff if they
understand grid well they're going to do
the grid stuff and they'll overwrite the
old stuff and so that's absolutely fine
you're not going to have any problems
unless there are some places where your
grids supporting browsers are going to
use some of the non grid code and get
into a mess because sometimes there are
things that you're going to be
interpreted both by old browsers and by
new ones and this is a good example if
I've floated a div and given it a width
which is what we need to do in a floated
layout we have to give things a width of
the oil match up and then we turn it
into a grid item the width will become
not the width of the container but the
width of the track so it's going to go
really little and skinny so we actually
needs kind of for car code in this
example but CSS has fixed this one for
you too with feature queries and feature
queries are going to become your new
best friend they've got really good
support and we use them in the same way
that we use our other overrides it
doesn't matter that I 11 doesn't have
support for them because what we're
doing is we're checking we're asking a
browser do you have support for this
thing and then we write our new code
we've already done the stuff for the
fallback we're just overwriting it so we
would do this I'm gonna check I'm gonna
ask the browser do you support display
grid it's a bit like using a media query
we say at supports then in the brackets
what we're testing for the property and
values so here we're saying display grid
note that we're asking the browser if it
claims to have support we're not asking
whether it's got support that actually
works we're just gonna have to hope that
our browser vendors have done this well
and we're saying it's very good and then
we write our code inside just like media
queries so that's all we need to do in
this case I'm just setting my width back
to auto in production when I'm doing
this stuff what I'm finding is I've got
a stack of selectors where I have set
widths back to auto and got rid of
margins because I'm using grid gap to
create gaps in the grid you're not doing
a huge amount of writing like a
completely different layout I'm just
overwriting the bits that are going to
be interpreted in both scenarios it's
relatively straightforward once you get
into that way of working but it does
mean that you need to understand CSS how
to use the Cascade
how to create graceful fallbacks with
minimal code it's how CSS works so you
need to understand how CSS works and how
best to structure things if you've spent
the last few years using a framework to
write CSS it's really a great time now
to do a bit of catching up to go back
and look at how CSS actually works we
know without that sort of layer of stuff
on top of it to make sure you know how
to take advantage of these things it's
really worth spending that time I think
you know most people are going to be
able to spend a couple of days just
refreshing on how all that works and
make it a lot easier to start dropping
the frameworks and so on and using just
the native CSS that we've got because
really the fundamentals of CSS haven't
actually changed that much they're
pretty much the same things we've been
doing for 20 years and the nice thing
about really knowing the fundamentals of
CSS it means you can start using the new
shiny stuff in a good way without
causing a mess if you've been used to
using frameworks it can all feel like a
bit of a black box so it's definitely
worth having a look at what's happening
in CSS and just making sure that you do
understand the fundamentals of how
things work so we've also got a bunch of
questions I get that about well okay so
this CSS good layout thing it's really
great but I've started trying to do
something and I can't do this type of
thing or that type of thing you know why
hasn't this yet solved all of my
problems
and so I want to talk a bit about the
things that we're already discussing in
the working group and about what might
actually come next
you know once the level one spec is
pretty much finished and it's well
adopted in browsers so you know what
might come next and the first thing I
wanted to talk about really was this
idea of sub grits so when I showed the
example of the balloons and the layout
we had that caption and it didn't line
up with the caption next to it and this
is because that internal nested grid is
a completely separate thing so a grid
item you can set the display grid on it
you can make a grid itself but that grid
inside has no relationship to the outer
grid or anything else it's just a new
nest
grid the same is true with Flex items
something that would be quite nice would
PL to say here is my grid this is my
grid for my page and direct children of
the grid can sit on it but also their
children can go to the same grid lines
that would let us line up captions and
so on across the grid so this is a good
example of where we might want that and
this is exactly the sort of layout you
get from a designer who believes that
content comes out of the CMS with
perfect line length you've all had one
so you know that's fine and you think
that's a perfect grid layout that'll
take me no time at all there's my CSS
for that grid layout that's going to be
great and then of course we implement
that into the CMS and this happens and
the designer says no that's not what I
wanted we think when I'd like those to
line up across the row I want everything
to line up right across the row and we
can't because the internals of those
boxes aren't participating in grid
layout and we can kind of make it a bit
better than this what I might do is make
each card a flex item like this and then
I could push at least the the footer
down to the bottom of the box by setting
err flex one on the inner there and that
gives us at least this it's not it's
better than it was but it's not exactly
what we wanted what we really wanted was
everything to line up if the titles got
two lines it should all line up across
the row if the foot has got two lines
that should line up that would look
really neat now the sub grid spec that
was pushed into level two into the sort
of the real rough workings of a level
two spec would solve this problem so in
that spec our sub grid our main grid
would need to have four rows available
for each card because the card there's
got four elements as you can see so we'd
need to make sure we had space for that
in our outer grid and then we'd ask for
the direct route of the grid to span
four row lines and set the value of
display two sub grid and then basically
what we're saying is I used use the
outer grid for the entire
of the sub-grid which would give us in
this a mockup example something like
this where the elements inside are now
participating in those rows that are
defined on the parent
I mean reality which have to deal with
the gap and so on as gaps aren't
inherited as I say this is all at the
moment completely theoretical there
aren't any implementations of this but
it's something that I'm very keen to see
and I think a lot of people would like
that kind of ability in grid we just
need to work out how to do it it turns
out this stuff is fairly complicated
I've written a bit about that particular
feature and these slides I'll be showing
so you can get hold of them and there's
also links there to the actual issue on
the CSS working group drafts and all of
the CSS is discussed in the open we use
issues on github just like anything else
so if you have an opinion about some CSS
you can go and you can raise an issue or
comment on one of the issues that we've
got as that's something that anyone can
do and it's really really important that
web developers do that here's another
thing that people think when they first
look at grid they think that grid can do
this sort of masonry or Pinterest like
layout where so the box is all arranged
themselves nicely to fill a space and
unfortunate that's not quite the case
although people would really really like
it to be so we can kind of get somewhere
like that if we placed each item this
looks a little bit like a masonry layout
and that's why people I think get
confused and think that they can they
can do this so let's have a little look
good or out of placement gets his part
of the way there so with auto placement
we can take a bunch of stuff we can
throw it at a grid and grid we'll just
place those things one into each cell
and we can even do things like I've done
here cause some of the items to spam
tracks yeah span rows or columns and
they'll lay themselves out on the grid
so we can end it with something like
this and in this case grid is going
progressing forward it's got one two
three and then number four it just fits
that where it can so we're kind of
getting a bit of a masonry like view and
we can go as
further we can set grid Auto flow to
dents and then grid will back fill the
gaps which is slightly scary for an
accessibility point of view because
we're taking things out of their logical
order but might work for some types of
layout say a bunch of images that we
don't need to tab around but that would
give us this and it looks a bit like
masonry but it's not really masonry it's
still a strict grid with rows and width
columns like that you know we've still
got a grid there
what masonry looks like is more like
this the items kind of stay in document
order and they sort of shift up and down
to accommodate the different sizes of
boxes to do this with grid you need to
have a whole stack of row tracks
available and then position your items
using line based positioning so you can
get the look but it's not the same as
having stuff and just throwing it at a
grid and the browser just going tada
there it all is so currently the closest
way we have of doing something like
masonry is multiple column layout except
you then end up with things down columns
rather than across the row and motor-oil
is somewhat buggy once you end up with
you know boxes splitting and across
columns and various sub optional things
can happen so this is something that
again I've written about it so then
we've got an issue raised for its thing
that sort of been put into the level two
rough draft sort of saying this is
something we'd like to try and solve
it's almost a bit of a mixture between
grid and flexbox we don't quite know how
we're going to solve it but if you've
got ideas if you care about this sort of
stuff you can always go and comment on
the issue and then a final thing that
you may were run into is this I know you
can't style grid cells or areas
themselves you need to have an element
in there you need to put something in
there and then style that add borders
and so on to the element people would
quite like to be able to just style the
actual areas a bit like we can put a
column rule between multi-car elements
again we've got an issue raised over on
github about doing this this kind of
idea of maybe having some sort of pseudo
element that you can style and it's in
pseudo element so we can get
somewhere to that already so this is
what I want to get to I've got a grid
layout with the white panel there and
that stretches right across the layout
sort of underneath the panel with the
images and to get the basic layout
without the background color I name my
areas using the grid area property and
I'm laying them out ASCII art style with
the value of grid template areas I want
us I've done that that's kind of my
layout and we get something like this we
haven't got the white panel but we've
got everything in the right place if I
overlay the areas you can see if I added
the white background to the top and
bottom I wouldn't have the effect if
it's spamming underneath the bar with
the images and so what I really want to
do is kind of be able to just style an
area on the grid I don't want to have to
put something in to do that and
certainly use a couple of techniques to
achieve the results I want now firstly
you need to know that when you use grid
template areas to layout named grid
areas you get named lines created from
the area names so each area is
surrounded by named lines and you can
position things against the lines just
like any other line on the grid which is
pretty handy so I need to find four
lines that correspond to the area
covered by the white background and it's
pretty hard to annotate lines on this
image because areas can have multiple
lines because obviously as the different
areas bump up against each other we get
a start and end line for each thing so
we've got you know the column lines
there which could be title start content
top start content bottom start you know
we could pick any of those what I want
to do is find four lines that define my
area so I've picked them the title start
there four rows and content bottom end
four rows and content top start and
content top end for my column lines and
you could pick any of that any of the
names that line up there and then use
the line names position some generated
content so I'm actually using some
generated content and I'm going to that
position that sort of stretch that
across that whole area and what this
also demonstrates
another feature of grid you can place
things into already occupied cells so
you can stack those things up and you
use the index just like absolute
positioning to control the stack and
that gives us our apparent grid area
background color so there's lots of ways
you start to poke at grid layout it's a
huge spec it's not a lot of it there's
lots of ways we can kind of stop playing
with these ideas to achieve things that
we might think aren't quite possible I'm
convinced there are lots of ways that
people are going to start playing with
this stuff and coming out with
interesting ways to achieve things and
maybe some of those things would let
inform what we do at the CSS working
group to make all of this easier and so
do play with this stuff but remember you
know this is all new I've been messing
around with it for years but I've only
been able to use it in production since
March and it's a big change you know
using something just to create little
examples to teach people to actually
using into production solving real
problems I'm starting to discover things
about the spec and how things work that
I'm sort of haven't been really aware of
so we're all still figuring things out
we're all still learning so if you
manage to solve a problem with new
layout write about it you know let
people know what you've done it's going
to help someone else out and if you hit
an unsolvable one write about that too
because that might be useful for making
this stuff better in the future you know
do write about what you've learned share
it tell the citizen group what's missing
and you know this is your platform to
create on and I certainly want you know
as part of that work I do with the
surface working group I want to make
more things possible because I've been
doing CSS for 20 years I still find it
really really interesting and exciting
and I enjoy sharing this stuff and yeah
I'd like to see what we can achieve in
the next few years to what more can we
do with this platform now if you're not
experimenting with grid yet I've got a
bunch of stuff that might help
goodbye example is a site I put together
and I'm still adding stuff too with
examples as a whole video tutorial you
can find out about all the little things
that I've discussed today on that site
broken down into details I know this has
been a bit of a fly-through and I wrote
the guides for mdn if you like reading
rather than watching videos that's a
good place to go lots of stuff on my
site and grid bugs is where I collect
the the Interop issues that were finding
grids really stable across the
implementations but there's obviously
little bits that we're discovering where
it hits up against of the layout methods
or whatever if you find a problem then
I'd love to know about it so that we can
get it raised with the browsers and get
it fixed and if you like all this sort
of stuff and I have next month a new
book coming out the new CSS layout which
talks a lot more about this kind of
stuff with layout and how to use layout
in the real world so thank you very much
for listening some all of this
you